[Music]
welcome back to CBS morning's
communities in Mississippi and Alabama
are still reeling from a massive tornado
that ripped through the region on Friday
night killing at least at least 26
people injuring dozens more the National
Weather Service says the tornado was an
ef-4 with wind speeds up to 170 miles an
hour yikes it was on the ground for more
than an hour President Biden has
declared a state of emergency in
Mississippi and he's sending Federal
funding to devastated areas including
hard hit Sharkey County in one of the
poorest parts of the state our own
lanazak traveled there and visited
Rolling Fork a town of roughly 2 000
people mostly flattened by this storm
she spoke with a local Diner owner who
described hiding with her employees in a
walk-in cooler as a storm rapidly
approached them
well we got the last 20 and then I went
in and then my husband came in and he
was holding the door and it got away
from him and I'm just pulling and I
don't know how but he got it back and
when he got it here he looked up and he
said
as he's closing it he said I see the sky
and so that meant our roof was gone
and when we got out
it was chaos we come around the building
and then people are just screaming
coming from the highway trying to get
back here to find their families and you
just hear screaming of this one's name
and that one's name and these are people
you know and you know they were home
then you don't know where they are